obviously I've been gone for a really
long time
Olivia Jade posts her first youtube
video in 8 months I didn't know exactly
when I should come back to YouTube but
the reason for that is just because I'm
legally not allowed to speak on anything
going on right now the 20 year old
alluding to parents Laurie Lachlan and
Massimo Janu Lee's alleged involvement
in the college admissions candle earlier
this year Sunday marks the first time
she's posted a video since that news
broke and in the two minute clip Olivia
explains to her nearly 2 million
followers why she's finally ready to
move on with her life I debated for like
seven or eight months like well if I
can't talk about it is there a point in
coming back and not being able to say
anything I want to come back because I
want to come back this is the best I can
do and I want to move on so hurt because
I'm not trying to like make this about
me or like how I've been because it it's
not the point of this though I'm
terrified to make this video and to come
back I know that I also want to start
taking smaller steps in the right
direction
meanwhile a source told ET in November
that Olivia and her 21 year old sister
Isabella are getting more and more
worried about their mom Lori who we're
told is at an all-time low as she
continues to fight charges in connection
with the college admissions scandal I
think the likelihood that Lori spends
prison time is very very high because of
the seriousness of the crime and the
amount of money that we're dealing with
here last month
ET confirmed that Lori and matza Mo's
legal team officially entered not guilty
pleas to new charges of conspiracy to
commit federal program bribery at the
time a source told ET quote she is
breaking down adding she truly feels
that her very worst people are coming
out in support of her lately
but she is afraid to open up she's
concerned if she talks to the wrong
people that her opinions will get out
and somehow affect the case Lori and
Massimo are accused of paying
five hundred thousand dollars in bribes
to get their daughters admitted to USC
as recruits for the crew team even
though neither of them had ever
participated in the sport I just want
them to have that experience and get
that education and have a degree to fall
back on in April the couple submitted
not guilty pleas and now Olivia and
Bella are no longer enrolled at USC I
want them to be happy so I want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I really want that
for them et's source says Lori's
daughters are trying to help her process
but it's been really hard the girls feel
guilty because they realize she was only
trying to help their future they know
their mother is a good person and don't
want her to suffer in any way
[Music]